สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนสู่ห้องเรียนภาษา
ไทยห้องเรียนด้วยการฟัง
compensable ไยค่ะแล้วก็ในวันนี้เนี่ย
ครูปุ๊กกับครูชิก็มาพบกับนักเรียนทุกคนนะ
คะในวันอะไรคะูชิวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะครู
ปุ๊กวันาจารย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ 19 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์เป็นเดือนที่ 2
ค่ะปีพ.ศที่เท่าไหร่คะ 2  5  6  7 พ.ศ
เท่าไหร่คะ
2024 ค่ะค่ะนะวันนี้ครูปุ๊กครูชิมาพบกับ
นักเรียนทุกคนนะคะในวันจันทร์ที่ 19
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์ปีพุทธศัก
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะนะ
อื้อหือวันนี้เรามาเจอกันอีกแล้วอีกแล้ว
ค่ะูชิต้องเจอกันอีกแล้วบ่อยๆ
ค่ะเฮ้ยแต่วันนี้เนี่ยเป็นเรื่อง
ที่ไม่ไม่หัวเราะไม่ได้ค่ะ
อ้าวเป็นเรื่องเศร้าเหรอคะใช่ค่ะนะเป็น
เรื่องที่เราเรียกว่าโศกนาฏกรรม
นะโศกนาฏกรรมเนี่ยภาษายากมากนะน่าจะเป็น
แวาน
ค่ะโศกเนี่ยก็คือความเศร้านั่นแหละเสียใจ
อ่าความเสียใจความเศร้าโศกนะคะนาฏกรรม
เนี่ยมันเป็นแบบเหมือนกับเหมีเหตุการณ์
ที่หรือเรื่องราวที่ฟังแล้วมันดูเศร้าสลด
สลดก็คือใจเรามันรู้สึกแบบฟังแล้วแบบมัน
สลดอ่ะ
มันเหี่วอ่าใช่มั้ยมันห่อเหี่ยวมันรู้สึก
ไม่ดีมันรู้สึกแย่แต่ว่าเราก็ต้องเอามา
สอนบ้างเพราะว่ามันเป็นภาษาไทยเนาะที่นัก
เรียนอาจจะไม่ค่อยได้ฟังไงนะเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยมันก็จะต้องมีเรื่องที่ดีเรื่องที่
สนุกเรื่องที่มีความสุขนะแต่ว่าเรื่องที่
มีความทุกข์ความโศกเศร้าเสียใจบางทีเราก็
ต้องเอามาสอนบ้างเนาะอื้อหือครูปุ๊กก็เลย
คิดว่ามีเหตุการณ์ใหญ่ๆที่เกิดขึ้นในโลก
ของเราเนี่ยนะเพราะว่าโลกของเราเนี่ยนะ
ครูปุ๊กก็มีเหมือนกันนี่ค่ะโลกของครูปุ๊ก
อือโลกของเราของเราหมายถึงทุกคนนะ
คะของครูด้วยของนักเรียนด้วยไม่ว่านัก
เรียนจะอยู่ประเทศอะไรนะก็อยู่ในโลกเดียว
กันนะคะแล้วบางทีเรื่องราวแบบเนี้ยมันไม่
ได้เกิดในประเทศครูนะอาจจะเกิดในประเทศ
ของนักเรียนหรือประเทศของเพื่อนบ้านนัก
เรียนนะคะแต่ไม่ได้เกิดในประเทศเราแต่
เวลาเราฟังแล้วเนี่ยมันมีความเศร้ามีความ
เสียใจว่าทำไมจึงเกิดขึ้นมันเกิดจากอะไร
เอออแล้วก็โศกนาฏกรรมเนี่ยมันสุดท้ายแล้ว
มันจะต้องบวกกับเรื่องเกี่ยวกับความตาย
ด้วยนะนะแต่ว่าเราเนี่ยก็ฟังไว้เพื่อเป็น
อุทาหรณ์เนอุทาหรณ์หมายถึงเป็นเรื่องที่
เกิดขึ้นแล้วเราเอามาเรียนรู้แล้วก็เอามา
ไว้เตือนตัวเองว่ามันสามารถจะเกิดเหตุ
การณ์แบบนี้ได้นะเวลาเราไปแบบนี้เราจะเจอ
ปัญหาอะไรแล้วก็มันเหมือนเป็นเก็บเป็น
ประสบการณ์ไว้นะแล้วเวลามันเกิดเหตุการณ์
กับเราจริงๆเนี่ยเราจะได้มีวิธีการที่เรา
อาจจะเคยคิดไว้แล้วแล้วก็แก้ไขสถานการณ์
นะก็อาจจะเป็นเรื่องที่เอาไว้เตือนเราเอง
นะแล้วก็นะมันก็จะได้เป็นอุทาหรณ์เนี่ย
แหละค่ะนะไว้สอใจเราออืใช่แล้วบางทีเนี่ย
เวลาเรารู้เนี่ยเราจะได้ได้ระวังมากขึ้น
เพราะบางทีเราทำไปโดยที่เราไม่คิดว่ามัน
เป็นเรื่องใหญ่ไงเพะมันผิดาตอะไรขึ้นมา
มันเกิดครูชิยกตัวอย่างอย่างเช่นสมมุติ
ครูชิขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์นะขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ออก
มาจากซอยแล้วออกมาเร็วพอเห็นรถแล้วคูชิ
เบรกแต่รถที่มาเร็วก็อาจจะหักหลบ
มอเตอร์ไซค์คูชิอ่ะแล้วก็ไปชนกับรถชนกับ
อะไรที่แบบมากกว่านั้นคือถ้าเคตัดสินใจชน
คูชิเนี่ยคูชิก็บาดเจ็บคนเดียวปรากฏว่า
เค้าจะช่วยเราเนี่ยเหักหลบเราเนี่ยไปชน
กับคนอื่นอีกมากมายอันเนี้ยครูชิก็ต้อง
เตือนว่าเวลาจะขับรถแล้วออกไปอย่างเร็วๆ
เนี่ยต้องช้าลงแล้วก็มองซ้ายมองขวามอง
ซ้ายมองขวาให้ดีก่อนที่แบบเราจะยื่นออกไป
จนเาแบบตกตกใจอ่ะใช่มั้ยอันเนี้ย
นี่ก็เป็นอุทาหรณ์ได้เหมือนกันนะหรือว่า
เราดูข่าวเนี่ยมันเกิดเหตุการณ์นี้เหตุ
การณ์นั้นเนี่ยเราก็เอาไว้เตือนตัวเอง
เหมือนอย่างที่ครูชิบอกใช่มยว่านะว่าคราว
ต่อไปเนี่ยเราขี่เราก็จะระมัดระวังมาก
ขึ้นนะหรือว่าในอุบัติเหตุใหญ่ๆในโลกของ
เราของเราเนี่ยที่ทำให้คนเนี่ยยังจดจำ
เพราะว่าอาจจะเป็นเพราะว่ามันเป็นเหตุ
การณ์ที่ทำให้คนเนี่ยเสียชีชีวิตเยอะนะ
แล้วก็มันอันตรายใช่มยนะซึ่งมันไม่ใช่แบบ
ภัยพิบัติทางธรรมชาติไงไม่ใช่เกิดจากเหตุ
ของธรรมชาติอย่างสึนามินะหรือว่าภูเขาไฟ
ระเบิดบุ้งแล้วก็มีลาวาออกมาเคนอ่าเอ่า
อันนั้นน่ะมันเป็นเหตุที่เราเนี่ยอาจจะ
แบบป้องกันอาจจะยังไม่ได้ 100% นะมันก็นะ
แต่ว่าอันเนี้ยมันอาจจะเกิดจากเหตุที่คน
ที่ประมาทหรือคิดไม่ถึงแล้วก็ทำให้เกิด
เหตุการณ์ใหญ่ๆขึ้นมาอย่างเงี้ยนะก็อาจจะ
เป็นสิ่งที่เราสามารถจะป้องกันได้ไงนะอ่า
อยากรู้แล้วคะครูปุ๊กเหตุการณ์แรกเนี่ย
เกิดที่ถนนเกิดที่แม่น้ำเกิดที่ภูเขาเกิด
ที่ไหนคะ
เกิดที่ถนนค่ะนะอ่าเกิดที่ถนนในประเทศจีน
เนาะนะโอแล้วก็แล้วเป็นเหตุการณ์เกิดขึ้น
ยังไงโอ้โห
โอดูสิคะว่าเกิดแบบนี้ได้ยังไง
นะถ้าเราเนี่ยนี้ต้องขยาย
ค่ะถ้าเราไม่ได้ดูข่าวเราเห็นภาพนี้ครั้ง
แรกเนี่ยเราคิดถึงอะไรนะโอ้โหนี่แสดงว่า
รถเนี่ยวิ่งมากันเร็วมากแล้วก็อาจจะเกิด
จากความประมาทของใครสักคนแล้วทุกคนก็เบรค
เบกหักหลบเบรกหักหลบชนกันแบบกี่คันคะ
เนี่ย 200 กว่าคันค่ะครูชิอ 200 กว่าคัน
นี่ค่ะยาวเลย
นะเพราะว่าอันเนี้ยเป็นสะพานที่ประเทศจีน
ค่ะเกิดเหตุเกิดที่ประเทศจีนนะนแล้วก็
แล้วก็ถนนที่เป็นแบบสะพานเนาะใช่มั้ยใช่
ค่ะเป็นซุปเปอร์ไฮเวย์หรือเปล่าเนี่ยอื
ใช่ค่ะูชิเนื่องจากว่าคืออย่างงี้มันเกิด
เพราะว่า
เอ่อหมอกค่ะหมอกหมอกเนี่ยก็คือเป็นตอน
เช้าๆเนาะมันก็จะมีไอน้ำที่ลอยขึ้นใน
อากาศเแหละนะแล้วก็ทำให้เกิดแบบสีขาว
คล้ายๆควันนะถ้าแบบเราสูบบุหรี่อ่ะอ่าใช่
แล้วค่ะหมอกนะหมอกเยอะบนภูเขาใช่ค่ะแล้ว
บางทีเนี่ยในประเทศแบบที่แบบมีอากาศเย็นๆ
เนาะตอนเช้าๆมันก็จะมีหมอกเยอะอแล้วบางที
เราเรียกว่าหมอกลงจัก
นะจัดก็คือว่ามีหมอกเนี่ยหนามากๆนะทำให้
ระยะการมองเห็นเนี่ยเา้าบอกว่าประมาณซัก
200 มตมั้งูชิเห็นแค่ 200 มตเพราะฉะนั้น
ขับรถเนี่ยต้องไม่เร็วใช่มั้ยต้องขับช้าๆ
ใช่มั้ยใช่แต่ว่าก็น่าจะไม่ค่อยมีใครช้า
กันมากเท่าไหร่คืออาจจะช้าลงแต่ว่า 200 ม
อ่ะคุณชิคิดว่าระยะเบรคเนี่ยต้องช้ากี่
เมตรอือ้าถ้าเกิดมันขึ้นอยู่กับความเร็ว
นะครูปุ๊กถ้าเราขับรถเร็วระดับเป็น 100
เนี่ยเราต้องเตรียมระยะการเบรกสัก 60
เมตนะใช่มแต่ถ้าเราวิ่งแบบ 60 กมระยะเบรก
เนี่ย
เอ่อใช้ใช้ระยะทางเบรก 4 เมตก็น่าจะโอเค
อืใช่มยนะแต่อันเนี้ยก็คือว่ามันก็เลย
กลายเป็นอุอุบัติเหตุเพราะว่าทัศนะเราบอก
ว่าเราเรียกว่าทัศนวิสัยอุ๊วันนี้ศัพท์
ยากๆเยอะเลยเนาะโอ๊ดีค่ะเพราะว่าตอนนี้เ
เป็นิอระดับสูงแล้วนะก็เอนักเรียนฟังผ่าน
ๆหูเนาะนะโศกนาฏกรรมก็คือเหตุการณ์ที่มัน
เศร้าเสียใจมากๆสุดท้ายมันจะมีคนตายหรือ
เสียชีวิตนะแล้วก็เป็นอุทาหรณ์อุทาหรณ์ก็
คือเป็นเหตุการณ์ที่เกิดขึ้นแล้วเอามาสอน
เราได้นะให้ใช้ชีวิตอย่างไม่ประมาทหรือ
ว่าไม่ต้องระมัดระวังนะอือนะแล้วก็
อันเนี้ยก็คือนะเป็นเหตุการณ์ที่บางคนอาจ
จะแบบนะใช้ชีวิตด้วยความประมาทด้วยนะ
อือหือ
ว่ามีหมอกลงจัดนะคะแล้วหนามันมองเห็นแบบ
ไม่ไกลมันมองเห็นได้ระยะใกล้ๆเพราะฉะนั้น
ถ้าคุณขับเร็วเกินไปเนี่ยคุณอาจจะเบรคไม่
ทันอใช่ค่ะถึงบางทีเนี่ยครูชี้เบรกแล้ว
ครูชี้เบรกทันนะแต่มันก็ใกล้คันข้างหน้า
ครูปุ๊กมาเนี่ยเบรคไม่ทันก็ชนูชิไปชนคัน
ข้าง
หน้าก็คือบางทีเนี่ยูชิเบรกทันแต่คนข้าง
หลังูชิเนี่ยเบรกไม่ทันค่ะก็เลยชนก็เลย
เกิดอุบัติเหตุที่ใหญ่ขนาดนี้นะใช่ค่ะนะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยมันก็เลยเกิดแบบโอ้โห
แสดงว่าก็คือหมอกเนี่ยลงหนามากนะเค้า
เรียกหมอกลงจัดนะทำให้ทัศนวิสัยก็คือการ
มองเห็นเนี่ยไม่ดีนะพอไม่ดีปุ๊บมันก็เลย
เกิดเหตุการณ์อุบัติเหตุนะรถชนกัน 200
กว่าคัน
นะมีคนเสียชีวิตมั้ยหรือคนตายนี่แหละเสีย
ชีวิตมีมีค่ะแต่ด้วยความที่เขาคงมาไม่
เร็วกันมากนะก็มีผู้เสียชีวิตเนี่ย 1 คน
เท่านั้นอออืมีคนเสียชีวิต 1 คนแล้วคน
เจ็บล่ะบาดเจ็บก็คงจะเยอะแต่เขาไม่ได้บอก
จำนวนมาว่าเจ็บเท่าไหร่แต่ว่าความเสียหาย
กับรถยนต์เนี่ยมีมากๆนะอือหือ
เพราะว่ารถยนต์บางคันเนี่ยก็อาจจะชนกัน
แรงบางคันก็ชนกันนิดหน่อยเพราะบางทีหัก
หลบนะการหักหลบอ่ะมันอาจจะไปชนคนอื่นด้วย
ไงหรือคนอื่นอาจจะมาชนคนที่หลบอย่างเงี้ย
ออเนก็อาจจะทำให้เกิดอุบัติเหตุเสียหาย
กันเยอะนะคะเนาะอ่ะเราอันเนี้ยก็คิดว่า
ทั้ง
รถเสียหาย 200 กว่าคันนะคะมีคนบาดเจ็บนะค
ซึ่งต้องไปโรงพยาบาลรักษาตัวนะคะแล้วก็
เอ่อมีคนเสียชีวิต 1 คนนะคะต้องบอกว่า
อันเนี้ยเป็นการชนกันที่แบบใหญ่มากปริมาณ
รถที่ชนกันเนี่ย 200 กว่าคันเนี่ยก็ถือ
ว่าเยอะมากแล้วก็น่าจะเยอะที่สุดที่
บันทึกไว้นะคะเราก็เลยเรียกว่าโศกนาฏกรรม
นะมีการมีอุบัติเหตุใหญ่ใช่ค่ะอืใช่นะอ่ะ
เรามามาดูอันนี้เป็นอุบัติเหตุทางบกเนาะ
หรือว่าที่ถนนนะเรามาดูอุบัติเหตุทางน้ำ
ที่เป็นอุบัติเหตุใหญ่ที่ทำให้คนเนี่ยจำ
ได้นะ
อื้อหืออุบัติเหตุทางน้ำเอ่อสิ่งที่ต้อง
วิ่งอยู่ในน้ำก็คือเรือใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะถูก
ต้องแล้วค่ะอืนะเพราะว่าอุบัติเหตุเนี้ย
เป็นอุบัติเหตุที่เกิดขึ้นที่ประเทศ
เกาหลีใต้นะไม่รู้ว่าครูชิเนี่ยพอจะจำได้
มั้ยที่เกาหลีใต้แล้วก็มีเรืออุบัติเหตุ
ทางน้ำเรือจมเรือ
ร่มใช่ค่ะ
นะก็คือเป็นเรือโดยสารที่เป็นเรือข้ามฟาก
ค่ะนะจะไปเอ่อเกาะเซจูเนาะนะประเทศเกาหลี
ใต้เ้ามีเกาะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยตอนนั้น
เนี่ยมีการพานักเรียนไปทัศนศึกษา
เออมีนักเรียนเนี่ยจากแผ่นดินเอ่อจากจาก
เอ่อแผ่นดินใหญ่นะแล้วก็นั่งเรือไปที่
เกาะเซจูอืใช่นะนักเรียนเยอะมั้ยคะโอ้โห
นักเรียนเนี่ยมีทั้งหมดเนี่ย
325 คนค่ะโอแล้วเป็นนักเรียนระดับมั
มัธยมมัธยมใช่ค่ะนะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยนัก
เรียนมัธยม
325 คนแล้วเป็นอาจารย์เนี่ย 14 คนนะ
อาจารย์ก็คือครูนี่แหละนะที่สอนนะ 14 คน
แล้วก็มีลูกเรือลูกเรือหมายถึงอะไรคะูชิ
ลูกเรือหมายถึงคนที่ทำงานในเรือค่ะอาจจะ
เป็นคนขับเรือคนที่เก็บตูกคนที่ขายของ
อยู่บนเรือนะคะหรือคนที่คอยโยนเชือกนะคะ
เราก็บเรือเป็นพนักงานบนเรือที่ทำงานใน
เรือนั่นเองนะก็มีพนักงานเนี่ยอยู่ทั้ง
หมด 36 คนเราเรียกว่าลูกเรือ
นะแล้วก็เรือเนี้ยจริงๆเนี่ยมันอาจจะมี
จำกัดน้ำหนักใช่ม
ว่าขึ้นได้เท่าไหร่กี่น้ำหนักเท่าไหร่ถึง
จะโอเคแล้วก็พอดีเขามีสินค้าค่ะสินค้าก็
คือของที่เขาจะต้องบรรทุกเอาไปขายที่เกาะ
นะเอาไปลงไว้ที่เกาะเพื่อเอาไว้ขายในเกาะ
อะไรแบบเนี้ยนะตอนนั้นก็มีโอ้โหบรรทุก
สินค้าไปอีก
2142  pro7 ตันนะโอ้โหเป็นตันนะนักเรียน
เป็นตัน 1 ตันก็ 1000 กกิโลกรัมอ่ะถูก
ต้องค่ะนะเพราะว่าจากเมืองอินซอนไปเกาะ
เซจูเนี่ยนะก็เนาะน้ำหนักเนี่ยมันมากรวมๆ
ทั้งหมดแล้วเนี่ย
3,600  608 ตันนะ
3608 ตันใส่ 0 เข้าไปเลย
ค่ะ
3,000
608 ตัน 08 สิคะ 608 ค่ะ 608 อ๋อ 8 ตัน
อือฮึ 608 ตันใช่ก็คูณ 1,000
ค่ะก็คือเติม 0 เลยค่ะ 3 ตัว
ก็ 3 ล้านกิลใช่นะ 3 ล้านกว่ากิโลนะซึ่ง
มันเป็นน้ำหนักที่มากเกินไปค่ะนะเค้าบอก
ว่าเกินกว่าที่จะรับได้ประมาณ 3.7 เท่า
อ่ะอันเนี้ยลูกเรือเนี่ย 38 คนนักเรียน
เนี่ย 300  36 ค่ะลูกเรือ 36  36 คนใช่
นักเรียน 325 ค่ะแล้วมีคนอื่นด้วยมั้ยครู
อีก 14 คนครู
เอ่อครูอีก 14 คนอื
นะแล้วก็นะที่บอกว่าบรรทุกสินค้าหรือของ
ที่จะเอาไปขายหรือเอาน้ำเอาอะไรไปก็แล้ว
แต่เนาะนะอีก 2,000 กว่าตันนะก็เลยเป็น
น้ำหนักที่มากเกินกว่าเรือเนี่ยนะไปถึง
3.7 เท่าเลยนะูชิเกือบๆ 4 เท่าของเรือ
ที่จะรับเลย
นะสมมุติว่าเรือเนี่ยรับได้
เอ่อรับเอ่อเรือรับได้ 1
100,000 เอา 100 ก็ได้ง่ายๆอาฮะอ้า 100
ตันใช่มั้ยรับได้ 100 ตัน
นะแล้วมันมันมากก็คูณอันนี้คือกิโลใช่
มั้ยชิ +  3 กิโกรัมอือ
ฮึแล้วก็มันเกินกว่าลิมิตไป 3  3 เท่าจ7
อ่ะค่ะอ 3.7
เท่าก็คือบรรทุกไปเนี่ยนะ
นั่นแหละค่ะ
โอ้โหเห็นมยมันบรรทุกไป 3  3  3  3 ล้าน
กว่านะฮะเกินจากที่มันควรจะบรรทุกแค่
100,000 ตัน 100,000 กกสุชิผิดค่ะ
300,000 สิคะ
300,000  3 เท่า 3.7
3.7  3.7
370,000 ตัน
อืไม่ใช่ 3 ล้านอือฮะอือค่ะอืออือฮึเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยมัน
เกินอันนี้ยกตัวอย่างแสดงว่าอันเนี้ยเค
ต้องสามารถบรรทุกได้ประมาณเอ่อก็ 1 ล้าน 1
ล้าน 1 ล้านกิโลเนอะใช่ 1 ล้านกิกรัแต่
บรรทุกไป
3  3 ล้าน
อืโอ้โหมันก็เกินเกินลิมิตของความสามารถ
ของเรือที่รับน้ำหนักได้นะอือฮึแต่ว่า
เค้าอาจจะคิดว่ามันโอเคไงมันมันมันแค่ไม่
ไกลมากใช่มั้ยก็อาจจะเป็นความคิดว่า
ประมาทไงว่าตัวเองสามารถที่จะไปได้ค่อยๆ
ไปไปช้าๆได้
นะแล้วก็ปรากฏว่าเค้าบอกว่านะไม่รู้ว่า
คือตอนที่เค้าสรุปมาน่ะว่าเหดเนี่ยอาจจะ
เป็นเพราะว่าเรือเนี่ยออกนอกเส้นทางอือฮึ
แล้วเรือเนี่ยมันมีท้องเรือใช่มั้ยใต้
ท้องเรือเนี่ยท้องเรือเนี่ยอันนี้ข้างบน
ใช่มั้ยท้องเรือเนี่ยมันอาจจะแบบลงไปต่ำ
เกินไปซึ่งข้างล่างมันอาจจะมีเป็นหิน
โสโครก
เรืออือฮึนะ
ฮถ้าเกิดเรือเนี่ยมีน้ำหนักข้างบนเยอะใช่
มั้ยเรือมันก็จะจมลงไปเยอะแบบนี้ใช่อื
แล้วมันก็อาจจะไปชนหินศกก็คือเส้นทาง
เนี้ยเคยผ่านได้แต่ตอนเนี้ยเรือเนี่ยมัน
หนักมันกินกินน้ำลึกลงไปเยอะใช่มั้ยเรือ
มันอาจจะกี่ชั้นก็ไม่รู้นะอืมันกินน้ำลง
ไปเยอะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยที่มันเคยวิ่งได้
มันก็เลยไปชนกับหินโสโก่ะคะใช่ค่ะออตอน
ที่เา้าสรุปออกมานะว่ามันอาจจะเกิดจาก
ปัญหาว่าเรือเนี่ยอาจจะเดินทางออกนอกเส้น
ทางแล้วไปชนกับหินโสกโครกซึ่งอันนี้เป็น
คนที่อยู่ในเรือเค้าคนที่รอดชีวิตก็คือ
ไม่ตายเนี่ยเขาบอกใช่มั้ยแต่ว่าคนที่ดูแล
เกี่ยวกับเรือเนี่ยเคบอกเขาไม่ได้ออกนอก
เซนเส้นทางนะเส้นทางเดิมนะก็เลยคาดว่าอาจ
จะเป็นเพราะว่าน้ำหนักที่มันเยอะนะปกติ
เนี่ยมันอาจจะมีหินโสโครกอยู่ข้างล่าง
อยู่แล้วเนาะนะแต่เรือเนี่ยไม่เคยมีปัญหา
เพราะว่าน้ำหนักเนี่ยมันมันไม่ได้เยอะมาก
นะมันก็เลยทำให้ท้องเรือที่ไปอยู่ใต้น้ำ
เนี่ยในน้ำเนี่ยมันก็ไม่ได้เยอะมากมันก็
ผ่านไปได้แต่วันนี้เนี่ยเนื่องจากมีคน
เยอะด้วยนะมีสินค้าเยอะด้วยสินค้าก็คือ
ของที่ไปขายเนาะนะก็เลยทำให้น้ำหนักเนี่ย
มากปุ๊บก็เรือก็จมลงไปเยอะอืก็อาจจะเป็น
ไปได้ว่าอันเนี้ยแล้วไปชนเนี่ยกับหิน
โสโครกแล้วทำให้เรือเนี่ยแตกรั่วแล้วก็อ
จม
นะนั่นแหละค่ะเราเรียกว่า
โอ้โหเรือเนี่ยนะก็จมค่อยๆจมลงอย่างในรูป
ที่ครูปุ๊กให้ดูอ่ะแล้วอการช่วยเหลือ
เนี่ยมันอาจจะแบบนอนครูปุ๊กเปิดอีกทีนึง
สิคะได้
ค่ะ
นะเนี่ยค่ะเรือมันก็จะเอียงแบบนี้ค่ะค่อย
ๆเอียงเอียงเียงแล้วก็ค่อยๆจมลงไปเรื่อยๆ
ค่ะจมถึงแบบนี้เลยค่ะครู
ชิคือจากเอ่อตีลังกาคว่ำไปเลยค่ะ
อืเพราะว่าข้างแสดงว่าการถ่วงข้างล่างมัน
ไม่หนักพอนะข้างบนบรรทุกของหนักมากนะพอ
เวลามันไปชนอะไรมันก็เลยเหมือนกับเอนแล้ว
ก็ล้มลงไปเลยนะอก็เรือเอียงพอเอียงปุ๊บก็
ค่อยๆลงไปเลยนะอ่าจนกระทั่งแบบท้องเรือ
ที่เป็นสีดำนักเรียนเห็นมั้ยตอนนี้ภาพมัน
เล็กคือต้องขยายหน่อยอ่า
อจนกระทั่งแบบที่เห็นเอ่อใต้ท้องเรือมัน
จะเป็นเอ่อทาด้วยสีดำนะโผล่ขึ้นมาข้างบน
เลยใช่นะภาพต่อไปโผล่ขึ้นมาเลยค่ะเห็นมเ
ค่ะอือันนี้ค่ะไไอ้ตัวเรือที่มีคนอยู่
เนี่ยทิ่มลงไปเลยใช่คว่ำเลยก็ได้นะเรียก
ว่าคว่ำเนาะคุชิใช่เรือกว่ำลงไปเลย
โหแล้วแบบมีเนี่ยมีมีคนเสียชีวิตนะมีเยอะ
เลยค่ะูชิอันนี้เป็นเหตุที่เราเรียกว่า
สลดใจมากๆค่ะอันเนี้ยโศกนาฏกรรมจริงๆใช่
ค่ะเป็นการเสียคนคนเสียชีวิตเยอะมากมีคน
ตายเท่าไหร่คะตอนแรกเนี่ยเขาบอกไว้ว่า 295
คนค่ะนะแต่ครูุไปดูข่าวเนี่ยมีอีกข่าวนึง
เขาบอกว่าตอนนี้ก็คือแบบตายทั้งหมดเนี่ย
306 คนค่ะไม่ใช่ 395 ะอาจจะแบบ 36 คนเออ
นะคนที่แบบไปช่วยได้แล้วไปโรงพยาบาลอาจจะ
ตายเพิ่มอืใช่ค่ะนะก็เลยมีผู้เสียชีวิต
เยอะมากนะแล้วก็อันเนี้ยแหละเป็นสาเหตุ
นึงที่ทำให้ประธานาธิบดีเกาหลีใต้เนี่ย
ที่เป็นผู้หญิงเนาะก็เลยถูกให้ออกจาก
เหมือนโดนไล่อ่ะขับไล่เพราะว่าเค้าเอ่อ
ดำเนินการช้ามากคือเหตุวันเกิดเนี่ย 8 น
กว่า 10:00 นแจ้งข่าวไปก็ยังไม่ได้แบบ
เหมือนขาดการเหมือนประสานงาน 7 ชมงเนี่ย
ไม่รู้ยังไม่ได้ออกมาแสดงความรับผิดชอบ
หรือมาที่ทีวีแล้วก็มาแจ้งหรือว่าอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยหรือว่าเป็นคนสั่งการอะไรใดๆนะ
ก็เลยคิดว่ามีมีมีคนเขาก็เลยเหมือนกับว่า
เอ๊ะประธานาธิบดีไปไหนอือนะอาจจะยังนอน
อยู่หรือเปล่าทำไมแบบนะเกิดเหตุแล้วยัง
ไม่ออกมาแสดงอะไรสักอย่าง
นึงไม่ไม่มีไม่รีบทำการช่วยเหลืออย่าง
เร็วอย่างรวดเร็วทำให้มีผู้เสียชีวิต
จำนวนมากถูกใช่ค่ะแล้วก็น่าเศร้าเสียใจ
มากเพราะว่าเป็นเด็กเด็กนักเรียนนะเด็กมา
มัธยมนะซึ่งครั้งนั้นน่ะก็จำได้ว่ามีนัก
เรียนคนนึงที่เป็นเหมือนหัวหน้าหัวหน้า
เป็นประธานนักเรียนหรืออะไรเนี่ยเว่ายน้ำ
เพื่อช่วยเพื่อนช่วยไปช่วยมาจนเขาหมดแรง
อ่ะเคเสียชีวิตในนั้นด้วยนะเป็นเรื่องที่
เราอ่ะจดจำกันว่าโอ้โหโศกนาฏกรรมนี้เนาะ
เห็นมั้ยเรื่องเนี้ยไม่มีใครอยากให้เกิด
แต่เมื่อเกิดแล้วเนี่ยแล้วมันสูญเสียแล้ว
เนี่ยก็เป็นเหตุให้เราเนี่ยเวลาเราจะพา
นักเรียนไปไหนไปเที่ยวยังไงมีจำนวนคนเยอะ
เราต้องคิดนะว่าทุกคนจะต้องปลอดภัยก็ต้อง
ใส่เสื้อชูชีพหรืออะไรแบบเนี้ยนะเพื่อไม่
ให้เราจมใช่มั้ยแล้วเด็กๆเนี่ยอาจจะจมน้ำ
ก็จะได้ตัวลอยขึ้นมาได้นะทุกคนก็เลยกลาย
เป็นว่านะอุบัติเหตุนี้แบบ่ขนาดเราไม่ใช่
คนเกาหลีใต้เรายังรู้สึกเสียใจจเลยนะ
โอ้โหูชิคะกำลังจะหมด
เวลาจริงๆอ่ะมีอุบัติเหตุทางอากาศอีกซึ่ง
มันเกิดขึ้นได้ยากนะแต่ว่ามันก็เคยเกิด
ขึ้นค่ะ
นะอุบัติเหตุเป็นอันนี้น่าจะเรียกว่า
เรื่องเหลือเชื่อ
นะใช่ค่ะนะอันนี้ก็เป็นโศกนาฏกรรมด้วย
เหมือนกันนะเพราะว่าเครื่องบินเนาะนะ 2
ลำมาชนกันได้ยังไงเพราะว่าเครื่องบินใหญ่
เนี่ยเป็นของซาอุดิอาระเบียค่ะนะเครื่อง
บินเล็กเนี่ยเป็นของคาซักสถานค่ะเป็น
เครื่องบินเช่าเหมาลำนะอ๋อปัญหาคือตรง
นั้นเพราปกติเครื่องบินโดยสารเนี่ยเขาจะ
มีเส้นทางการเดินเรือบินเนี่ยการเดิน
เครื่องบินเนี่ยอยู่แล้วแล้วก็เป็นที่รับ
รู้จะมีคนจัดแจงเหมือนจราจรทางอากาศให้
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้ก็มีค่ะนะแต่อันเนี้ยไปเกิด
เหตุที่อินเดีย
นะคือสนามบินคาทีอ่ะแล้วก็เหมือนเอ่อ
เครื่องบินเล็กเนี่ยก็ติดต่อมานะเขาก็บอก
ว่าโอเคให้บินรถระดับเาจะลงจอดใช่มั้ย
เขาคก็ให้ลดระดับลงมาเหลือ 15,000 ฟุตนะ
แล้วก็พอดีเครื่องบินของซาอุดิอาระเบีย
เนี่ยกำลังจะขึ้นนะแล้วเคก็เลยบอกว่าให้
เครื่องบินเล็กเนี่ยรักษาระดับนะเพราะว่า
มันกำลังจะบินสวนกันใช่มยแล้วก็ให้รักษา
ระดับให้อยู่ที่ 15,000 ฟุตเพราะว่า
เครื่องบินเนี้ยกำลังซาอุดิกำลังขึ้นไป
ถึง 14,000 ฟุตะนะแล้วก็แต่เอ่อเจ้าหน้า
ที่เนี่ยแจ้งเครื่องบินเล็กแต่ไม่ได้แจ้ง
เครื่องบินซาอุนะว่ามีเครื่องบินอีกลำนึง
เนี่ยบินอยู่ข้างบนใช่มั้ยแต่บอกข้างบน
เนี่ยให้ระวังนะแต่ปรากฏว่าเครื่องบินของ
คาซักสถานที่เช่าเหมาลำน่ะเค้าไม่รักษา
ระดับการบินนะก็บินลงมาในเอ่อลดระดับลงมา
นะแล้วก็ลดระดับลงมา 4,500 เอ่อ 14,500
ฟุตนะเครื่องบินก็ขึ้นแล้วพอลดลงมาอีกนิด
นึงก็เลยเกิดการชนกับกันเลยพอดีนะเเรียก
ประสานงานอันนี้เรามาเล่าถึงโศกนาฏกรรมนะ
ที่เกิดอุบัติเหตุอย่างอย่างใหญ่แล้วก็ทำ
ให้มีผู้เสียชีวิตจำนวนมากคะเวลาเรามด
แล้วค่ะครูปุ๊กนะคะเราก็ต้องลานักเรียนไป
ก่อนนะคะพบกันใหม่โอกาสหน้ากับเรื่องราว
ที่เราจะนำมาเล่าสู่กันฟังนะคะอ่าวันนี้
ก็ขอบคุณขคค่ะทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ